[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جواب
سلطان
ضربه الموجعه لايران بسلاحها المفضل
المسيرات ووستري جورنال تتحدث عن مسؤوليه
في اسرائيل
رجل الدبابات يعد روسيا لمعركه الربيع
صيانه الاسلحه تؤرق الخصمين وفولندا تزيح
العبء عن كياب
ولدينا ايضا في العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
زياره ميلوني تقسم حكومه الدبابه استقاله
وزير الاقتصاد والمؤسسات تتهم بعضها
بمخالفه القانون
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انه سيتحدث مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والسلطه الفلسطينيه لخفض
التصعيد وداع الاطراف كافه الى التحلي
بالهدوء
اااه السيسي
ما يهم هو التحلي بالهدوء وفي الايام
القادمه سنتحدث الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والسلطات الفلسطينيه
وقبل زيارته اسرائيل ورام الله اعلنت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تكليفه وزير الداخليه
باعداد قانون لحرمان منفذي الهجمات
وداعمهم من الجنسيه كما تعمل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على مشروعي قانونين الاول
لفصل داعم الهجمات من وظائفهم فورا دون
تحقيق والثاني للسماح بترحيل داعمي منفذي
الهجمات الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
لليوم الثالث على التوالي تشهد الاراضي
الفلسطينيه موجه من التصعيد هي الاعنف منذ
تولي حكومه نتنياهو زمام السلطه في
اسرائيل
39 قضوا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم
جنين نهايه الاسبوع وبعدها بيوم واحد قتل
سبعه مستوطنين برصاص فلسطينيه في القدس
احنا على مرحله ما قبل الحرب بخطوه فقط
وفي شعب وفي جيل صاعد هو اللي قايد هذه
المعركه وهاي المواجهه وهو لان هم ما
خلونا اشي ولا واقع على الارض
الغربيه اللي هو 2002 و 2001 و 2003 هذا
التصعيد يتزامنه مع جهود دوليه تبذل
لتهدئه الاوضاع في المنطقه عشيه زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطونيبلينج
امريكي فاعل
ومؤثر لمواجهه هذا الاحتلال وحمايه مصالحه
وقيمه ومصالح العالم وشريهان العالم
المستوطنين على الطرق الرئيسيه في الضفه
الغربيه
ومنازل الفلسطينيين القريبه من الشارع
ترافقها دعوات وقرارات اسرائيليه
بتسريع وتكثيف تسليح المستوطنين
تجاوز المستوطنون حد مهاجمه المركبات
الفلسطينيه بالقرب من المستوطنات وتوغلوا
الى داخل الكره الفلسطينيه واحرقوا هذا
المنزل وسط مخاوف الفلسطينيين من تكرار
العمل وايقاع الضحايا ما قد يؤجج الاوضاع
اكثر من بلده الترمس رام الله خالد القاسم
العربيه
لحركه فتح اهلا بك معنا سعيد الحوراني في
العربيه 360
بلانكين يقول بانه هو قادم لمحاوله
التهدئه بين الطرفين كيف تردون على ما ورد
في مقابلاته الخاصه مع العربيه
نعم انا في الواقع السيد بلانك انه وزير
خارجيه اداره بايدن التي كانت قد اطلعت من
البدايه وعود فيما يتعلق بفتح السفاره
الفلسطينيه في واشنطن وفتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في شرق القدس وغيره من العود
التي لم تنفذ
لي يقابل من قبل الحكومه متطرف المحكومه
بايديولوجيا خطيره قررت مسبقا ان تنفذ
تصعيد خطير شامل ضد شعب فلسطين الاعزل
بالمناسبه لهلا يكون هناك انطباع كان في
هناك دولتين او جيشين يتنازع عليهم هناك
شعب اعزل يناضل شبابه من اجل حريتهم على
ضوء ما وصل الامر من ناحيه السياسيه منه
وفق مسدود من وضع صائب من الاعتداءات
السعوديه وصادره اراضي الاعتداء على حياه
الناس التحدي الان مطروح امام السيد
بلانكن وان يستطيع بالفعل ان يضغط على
حكومه
لتوقف هذا الت الخطير والمميت ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني اذا كان يعني نفس الكلام اللي
بنسمعه همم يعني مش عبلومه طبعا يعني هذا
الكلام صحيح من قبلكم ولكن عموما يعني
كمواقف نفس الموضوع نفس الموضوع من منذ
همم يعني سنوات ان لم يكن من عقود رغم ذلك
الوليامبرز عندكم اليوم الرئيس الفلسطيني
كان قاعد معه يعني هل يصح هذا الكلام
الاجراءات العقابيه مش لازم تكون ايضا
تشمل بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين وهمم
يلتقي ايضا
هو كان هنا قبل اسبوع المشكله لدى الاداره
الامريكيه انه لن تستطيع حتى الان ان تفتح
جناح جانب الاسرائيلي الشعب الفلسطيني اخي
طاهر بالفعل في حال الدفاع عن النفس يعني
الان في هناك ميليشيا غير معلن عنها تشكلت
اصلا قبل تشكيل هذه الحكومه واليوم على
طريق على يد غفير وسميترتش تتبلور اكثر
وتتحول الى نواه الصلبه متوحشه تعتدي على
الفلسطينيين في الشوارع وتدخل قراهم
وتلحقهم في همم مزارعهم
وعند اشجارهم اذا نحن امام حاله اصطدام
تفاصيل مذهله اليوم اكثر من مدينه
فلسطينيه كانت قد اغلقت همم على حركه
الفلسطينيين همم ريحه الخليل ومدن في
الشمال يعني نحن نتحدث عن هجوم شامل على
الشعب الفلسطيني ما الذي سيفعله بينكن
الامر لا يتعلق الان بالفلسطينيين بقدر ما
يتعلق بالفعل بان تمارس هذه الاداره
الامريكيه ضغط واضع على اسرائيل اما الشاه
انتم شو قادرين تعملوا بصراحه
يعني الرئيس الوكالات الانباء شو عم تقول
اه لانه لم يعلق الرئيس الفلسطيني على
هجوم يوم الجمعه والقى بالمسؤوليه على
اسرائيل امس السبت في تصاعد العنف هل انت
يعني بينفع ايضا يعني انه يكون في هذا
الموقف من الرئاسه وهل ايضا تبني فكره
تحميل همم مسؤوليه تصاعد العنف الاسرائيل
كافي من قبل الرئيس الفلسطيني
سيدي حقيقه الراي العام الفلسطيني موضوعي
راي ناضج وغير متطرف رئيس الفلسطيني وكل
قياده الفلسطينيه لا تستطيع ان يعني تبني
سياساتها بشكل جوهري الا على اساس فهم
الراي العام الفلسطيني الراي العام
الفلسطيني يشعر بظلم شديد من هذا التصعيد
الخطير المسؤول عمليا للاحتلال لو لم يكن
هناك احتلال لما كان كل هذا ولكن قليل
اه نعم الان فهمتك الان فهمتك
لا لا شوف في هناك في هناك دور للسلطه
فيما يتعلق بعلاقات الدوليه وهي اعلنت
مجموعه من المواقف الرهان الحقيقي وعلى
الشعب الفلسطيني اللي بحسوا السليم يدرك
انه هو في حال الدفاع عن نفسه ولن يرفع
راي بيضاء ولكن انا اردت ان منوع ان الشعب
الفلسطيني اعزل يخوض حرب صعبه ونبيله تصور
شباب في عمر 18 ل 25 سنه يعني يقررون ان
يفعلوا ما يفعلون هذا لان الافق تماما
مسدود ولان الحريه عندما تحجب عن بشر
احرار سيبحث عنها بكل وسيله ممكنه للاسف
لا يوجد حكماء ولا عقلاء في اسرائيل حتى
لو كانوا اعداء هناك نظره هيدروجين عمياء
تعتمد على فائض القوه الاسرائيلي وتعتقد
واهمه انه بالقوه المجرده يمكننا ان تحل
الموضوع مع الشعب الفلسطيني لذلك الامور
بمنتهى الموضوعيه مرشحه لمزيد من التصعيد
نقول سيدي انا المطلوب بالفعل موقف عربي
منسق ومن اصدقائنا في العالم وفي الاقليم
يضغط في المؤسسات الدوليه وعلى الاداره
الامريكيه وعلى اصدقاء اسرائيل ليكبحوا
جماع هذا الحكومه لاحظ ان هذه الحكومه
متطرف الى الحد انها تعادي نصف المجتمع
الاسرائيلي نفسه يعني نصف الاخر الذي ايضا
يعني يعمل ضد الفلسطينيين ضاق ضرعا بهذه
الحكومه الاصوليه التي تريد ان تغير نمط
حتى حياه اليهود انفسهم بالامس برغم كل
الاحداث والتصاعدات ده خرج في تل ابيب
مظاهره ضمت عشرات الالاف ممن يريدون ان
يسقطوا حكومه نتنياهو اذا نحن امام مشهد
عبسي خطير لحكومه تمتلك كثير من ادوات
القوه
للشعب الفلسطيني والشعب الفلسطيني بالفعل
هذه الايام غير صموده على ارضه هو بحاجه
لعشقائه العرب بكل ما تحمل هذه الكلمه
الكلمه
اشقاء العرب على السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تحل
نفسها همم وتحمل الاحتلال مسؤوليه او تحمل
اسرائيل وصن او وصفه الاحتلال مع كل
مسؤولياته والتزاماته القانونيه الدوليه
لماذا تعطونها الشلل لا تزالون تعطونها
الشرعيه لوجود سلطه فلسطينيه
شفتي موضوع السلطه الفلسطينيه ليس امرا
موضوع حله من حيث المبدا لان السلطه
الفلسطينيه هي كائن سياسي له علاقات دوليه
عبر منظمه التحرير مع اكثر من 140 دوله هو
يرعى الصحه والتعليم وما الى ذلك انه
الموضوع هناك احتلال في اراضي 67 هذا امر
مفهوم للمجتمع الدولي ولكل اطراف المجتمع
الدولي الان اذا اسرائيل ارادت ان تقود
هذه السلطه هي تملك القوه لتقويدها
فلتقودها ولكن ان يخدم الفلسطينيين على
هذه الخطوه اعتقد ان الزمن لم يحن اا من
اجل ذلك ثانيا ان يعني ايجابيات وجود
السلطه في حياه الفلسطينيين اكثر من
سلبياتها هذا امر يخضع لحساب استراتيجي
مهم لا نريد ان نسقط في حاله من الفراغ
والفوضى لماذا اخي طاهر اسرائيل تريد ان
تحول الحال العامه الفلسطيني التي تمثلها
منظمه التحرير والسلطه الى حالات مجززها
في تمثلها بلديات لضرب مفهوم الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه لحساب مفهوم اخر المحليه
الفلسطينيه التي لا تعني للشؤون السياسيه
الاستراتيجيه او حق تقرير المصير انما
بالخدمات المتعلقه بالصحه والبلديات وما
الى ذلك شكرا جزيلا استاذ محمد الحوراني
يعضو المجلس الثوري لحركه فتح من رام الله
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
نعوده للمقابله الخاصه للعربيه مع
انتونيبلينكن فقد اكد الوزير الامريكي ان
اي عمليات عسكريه شمال سوريا لن تكون في
مصلحه اي من الاطراف وستؤثر سلبا في جهود
بحر تنظيم داعش
فيما يخص شمالي سوريا وان تهدئه الجميع
ولا نريد تدخل عسكريا الشمالي سوريا وهو
ما قد يؤخر الجهود لرضع تنظيم داعش ولن
يكون في مصلحه احد تركيا لديها مصالح
امنيه مشروعه واعتقد انه يمكن تحقيقها دون
تداخل عسكري فيما يخص النظام الاسد نحن لا
ندعم التطبيعه معه الامم المتحده اقترحت
عمليه لتنفيذ قراراتها ونحن ندعم ذلك الا
ان النظام الاسد يرفضها
استاذ الفلسفه السياسيه في جامعه كوريا
اهلا بك معنا همم دكتور كيف تقراون كلام
ليمكن في هذا موقف الذي اعطاه للعربيه
مساء الخير جميعا الموقف الامريكي ازاء
الملفين ازاء التدخل التركي والنيه رئيس
التركي
وتهديده لشراء شرق سوريا بالغزو واذا
التطبيع بدا اكثر وضوحا وجليا في الاونه
الاخيره همم سبق الوزاره الخارجيه سبق
الوزير الخارجيه تصريحات عن وزاره
الخارجيه وعن البنتاجون وعن الاداره
الامريكيه بالرفض القاطع لاي عمل عسكري في
الامن الاخيره ويبدو لي ان الرئيس التركي
ادرك هذه الرساله همم
وكانت كافيه لردعه لحد الان هذا الموقف هو
جديد تماما ولكن ان يلتزم ان يبقي على
التزامه بذلك همم كل ما تقدم الوقت اكثر
فاكثر باتجاه موعد الانتخابات التركيه
هذا هذا السؤال مهم انا لدي شكوك عميقه ان
الرئيس التركي وهذا يتعلق بمستويات
المنافسه الانتخابيه الداخليه ان الرئيس
التركي ما ان يشعر بفقدانه
للقاعده الشعبيه الاصوات ربما يغامر في
الفتره القادمه في الفترات المقبله قبل
الانتخابات يغامر
بعمليه عسكريه لاثاره الرغبات جمهور
القومي شارع القومي المتطرف في تركيا او
شارع يستجيب بسرعه لمخاوفه القوميه
والرئيس التركي على الدوامه يغزيها
ويغنيها لدى عوام تركيا بهذا الخصوص لهذا
السبب انا اتوقع بشده اذا شعر الرئيس
التركي انه انا خياراته بات الضعيفه في
الفوز في الانتخابات وليست هناك ضمانات ان
يقدم على مغامره هذه في كوباني او في
المحيطه وصرح ايضا همم الرئيس حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه المعتقل حاليا صلاح دي مرتعش
اظهر ابدا هواجسه هذا اليوم بهذا الخصوص
لهذا السبب علينا ان لا نركن الى
الطمانينه او اليقين بشان التزام الرئيس
التركي على الولايات المتحده
شكراديد الى اي مدى الاكراد سياسيا
وعسكريا يقومون بالدور اللازم المطلوب
منهم ايضا لطمئن التركي ولمعه اي عمليه
لم يسبق منذ منذ منذ منذ
لا على الاذى من سوريا همم لم يسبق
للاكراد القوم باعتداء من داخل الاراضي
السوريه على على تركيا ولا تستطيع الحكومه
التركيه اثبات ان ان عمل العسكريه ما قد
تم ضد مصالحه وحدود الحدود الحدود التركيه
مع شمال شرق سوريا هو الاكثر امر حتى من
حدود لها مع اليونان او بلغاريا او مع
ارمين يعني لهذا السبب تركيا كما باتم
عهدا تتخذ من فوبيا من
رهاب وجود المساله الكرديه المتطور مثلا
الكرديه سريعه للتدخل يعني على دوام تتخذ
من حزب العمال ومن غير حتى لو لم يكن حسب
من اي ذريعه اخرى
تقريبا
وسائل السلميه والعسكريه همم ضد فيها اليس
كذلك وبالتالي في قضيه هي قضيه امن قومي
بالنسبه الى تركيا وقضيه وجوديه ومصريه
بالنسبه الى الاكراد في الشمال السوري وفي
غير الشمال السوري يعني هي حصل كثير من
العمليات من قبل لا تتبلى عليهم همم حيث
لا يوجد اي شيء يحملون مسؤوليته
لا لا ليست هناك ليس هناك اعتداء من داخل
اراضي السوريه على الاراضي التركيه على
العكس من ذلك تركيا يتعايشت مع داعش لكنها
لا تستطيع ان تتعايش مع اداره مدنيه كرديه
المشكله تتعلق
بذهنيه السياسيه في تركيا وموقفها اذا
الوجود الكردي القضيه لا تتعلق لا بحزب
العمال ولا بغيره القضيه تتعلق بان تركيا
تعاني روبا تاريخيا مزمنا هذه مساله باتت
بمثابه ارجوزه نكررها في كل زمان
تركيا تعاني من عقده الكرد تركيا تدرك ان
اي اي اي طاقه واي تحرر كردي يشكل تهديدا
وجودا ومصريا بنسبه اليه بالنسبه للكرت
وجود تركيا ليست تحديدا في هذا يعني
النظافه
في النظام السوري تركيا الحل الحل هو
الرهان على معقدات الان باتت الولايات
المتحده حاسمه ايضا بسبب حاسمه بنسبه
لموقف اردوغان ومحاولته مقايضه التضحيات
السوريين والمتاجره بالشعارات والتحذيرات
التي سبق بها اطلاقها طوال اكثر من 11
عاما وقف ابدت ولايات المتحده موقفا حازما
اذا التطبيع مع نظام بشار الاسد واستطاعت
استطاعت الى حد كبير ان يؤثر على مسارات
التفاضيه حتى مشاري الاسد بان يستجيب
لمطالب اردوغان بالمصالحه كي كما يزعم كي
لا يمنحه فرصه في الفوز في الانتخابات
القادمه بكل الاحوال هناك هناك تضيق شديد
لخياراته لامكانات فوز الرئيس التركي لكني
مع ذلك كما اكدت من قبل الرئيس التركي
سيغامر حتى لو ادى ذلك بغرض همم استحواذ
على السلطه مجددا والبقاء فيها سيغامر حتى
دفعه الى الحرب الاهليه تركيا ليس فقط في
خارج تركيا وهذا النقاش
معه يعني انتهى وقت بس بكلمتين الاكراد
كمان بسوريا عم يحكوا عن النظام وعم
يتفاوضوا معه يعني ليش يعني حرام على
تركيا حلال على الاكراد بسوريا
لا لا الاكراد اصلا منذ البدايه لم
يتهاجروا باي قضيه ولا باي دم سوريا اي
مساله بدي هي ليس
مثل كان
يزرع في في مسجد الاموي واحمى وحلب خط
احمر وحماه خط احمر وحمص حتى بشار الاسد
يحكم قصر الرئاسه في انقر سياتي يوم ربما
يصلي اردوغان ورائه بدل بدل من العكس
مسؤوليته يعني مباشره شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
محمد
دكتور سعد بس نبي استاذ الفلسفه السياسيه
في جامعه كوريا تحياتي لك شكرا جزيلا
في العربيه 360 ايضا
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تقر بان الوضع في
الشرق صعب لكنها ما تزال تراه تحت السيطره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
ان اسرائيل
بايران واوضح المسؤولون ان الهجمات التي
استهدفت منطقه اصفهان بالامس تمت بمسيرات
واكدوا ان هذه العمليه تعد الاولى داخل
ايران في فتره حكم نتنياهو الجديده
لاسرائيل
قبل ذلك قال صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان
المسيرات التي استهدفت مواقع باصفهان
يعتقدوا انها انطلقت من داخل ايران وقالت
وكاله ايرنا ان ثلاثه مسيرات من نوع كواد
كابتر وراء استهداف اصفهان ما يمثل
اعترافا ضمنيا بانطلاقها من داخل ايران
كما اتهمت وسائل اعلام تابعه للحرس الثوري
الايراني اتهمت اسرائيل بالوقوف خلفه هجوم
اصفهان وهددت وسائل الاعلام تابعه للحرس
الثوري ايضا اسرائيل باستهداف في مصالحها
بالمسيرات
[موسيقى]
نذكر بان البنتاجون قال قبل قليل لم نشارك
باي عمليه عسكريه في ايران كما افادنا
مراسلنا بير غانم من واشنطن الذي ينضم
الينا الان بير مرحبا بك اي تفاصيل اضافيه
عن المعلومات التي لدي امريكا او الموقف
الذي اعلنته حول ذلك
الامريكيون حولوا من خلال التصريح الذي
ارسلوه الى العربيه ان يقولوا اولا ان
القوات الامريكيه لم تشارك باي عمليه او
غاره داخل ايران وقد اكد ايضا العقيد ترى
المتحدث باسم الفتاه العربيه اننا نراقب
الوضع ولكن ليس لدي اي معلومات اضافيه
اقدمها لك يقول هذا المتحدث باسم الفتاه
من الواضح ان اعلى امريكيين يريدون ان
يتركوا مسافه بعيده بينهم وبين هذه
العمليه والمصادر الاساسيه لهذه المعلومات
اما تكون غير معروفه الاسماء اما انها
تكون معلومات اسرائيليه همم طبعا
الاسرائيليون منذ اكثر من سنتين قدموا خطه
طويله ومفصله للامريكيين حول العمليات
التينا التي يريدون القيام بها ضد ايران
وقام بذلك وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي حين ذلك
جنس همم
والامريكيون حتى في اا ذلك الحين لم
يتبنوا ال الخطه الاسرائيليه لكنه من
الواضح انهم قدموا لفترات طويله الدعم
لهذه العمليه
ويعني همم نتابع في هذا الموضوع وفي
السياق اللي عم تذكره مثل ما هو واضح ايضا
تذكيرا لما تذكر الاخبار العاجله على
الشاشه عن انه الامريكيين يريد ان يريدون
الابتعاد عن اي صله تربطهم بعمليات اصفهان
همم هل هناك ايت معلومات قالها همم يعني
او يعني صدرت عن مسؤولين امريكيين همم
بخصوص ما يمكن ان
يفصله ان يفصله او ينقله وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي اثناء زيارته لاسرائيل في هذا
الموضوع تحديدا خاصه وان هناك معلومات
تحدثت او تصريحات تحدثت عن نقل الامريكيين
رساله للايرانيين عبر طرف ثالث
ما شاهدناه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين هو
على الشكل التالي المواقف الامريكيه اصبحت
اكثر التشددا من ناحيه اللهجه ضد ايران
وهناك تاكيد اكثر على التعاون مع اسرائيل
لمنع التمدد النفوذ الايرانيه او التهديد
الايراني لاسرائيل وهناك كلام متشدد اكثر
لجهه مناعه ايران من امتلاك السلاح
النوويه ما شاهدنا عليه ايضا خلال هذا
الاسبوع هو اكبر مناورات من الممكن ان
نشهدها بين الامريكيين والاسرائيليين وهي
كانت محاكاه لعمليه ضخمه ضد الاراضي
الايرانيه ولكن ما يقصده الامريكيون من كل
ذلك هو الردع وليس القيام بهذه العمليه
والمقصود بالرد هنا هو ان يقول لي
الايرانيين انهم لديهم القدرات مع
الاسرائيليين ولوحدهم للقيام بعمليه ضد
ايران وبالتالي على ايران ان تتوقف عن
المتابعه في تطوير البرنامج النووي
الايراني وبالتالي يعتبر الامريكيون ان
تلك كانت هي الرساله الاساسيه
طيب نحن يمكن ان نتابع في موقف بلنكن عن
ملف ايران تحديدا في مقابلاته مع ناديه
البلبيسي على يعني في هذه المقابله الخاصه
ونشكرك الان بير غانم مراسل العربيه من
واشنطن
الان يتجه نحو الاحداث العديده مثل قمع
المظاهرات في ايران النساء يدافعنا عن
حقوقهم ويتم قمحهن بعنف من قبل النظام وفي
نفس الوقت نرى ايران تدعم روسيا في حربها
ضد اوكرانيا وتقدم لها المسيرات والاسلحه
الاخرى ونرى ايضا ان الدبلوماسيه هي الحل
الوحيد لبرنامج ايران النوويه والرئيس كان
واضح ان كل الحلول مطروحه لمنع ايران من
الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
انها ستجلي موظفي سفارتها في ايران وافراد
عائلاتهم وذلك بعد يومين من هجوم شانه
مسلح واسفر عن مقتل حارس امن واصابه شخصين
واخرين ووصفته باكو بانه عمل ارهابي كانت
وزاره خارجيه اذربيجان اعلنت بعد الهجوم
انها استدعت السفير الايرانيه في باكو
للمطالبه بتحقيق العداله واعل الشرطه في
طهران اعتقال شخص يشتبه بصيرته بالهجوم
لكنها ذكرت انه يبدو ان دوافع المسلح كانت
شخصيه وليست سياسيه
ايران تاريخ من الاعتداءات على السفارات
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه عام
1979 اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه بتهران
واحتجاز رهائن امريكيين لمده اربع 444
يوما عام
1987 اعتداء على مقر السفاره السعوديه
عام
1988 متظاهرون يهاجمون السفاره الاتحاد
السوفيتي
عام 2009 متظاهرون ايرانيون يهاجمون
السفاره الباكستانيه في طهران عام 2011
اقتحام السفاره البريطانيه بعد فرض عقوبات
بسبب برنامج اغراض النووي عام 2016
كشف وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق مايك
بومبي في كتابه لا تبدل رايك مطلقا القتال
من اجل امريكا التي احب كشفت تفاصيل اتخاذ
قرار وتنفيذ عمليه قتل قائد الحيض الحرس
الثوري الايراني قاسم سليمان في بغداد
مطلع سنه 2020 من قبل الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ومسؤولينا في ادارهته
بعد ثلاث سنوات من الحادث وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابقه مايك بومبي ويكشف
كواليس عمليه اغتيال قائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني
القصه بدات حينما كتب بومبيو رساله الى
سليماني هدده فيها بان امريكا ستحاسبه
وستحاسبه ايران على هجماتها ضد المصالح
الامريكيه في العراق لكن الاخيره لم يرد
سنحاسبك وسنحاسبه ايران على هجماتها ضد
المصالح الامريكيه في العراق بعد ذلك
بسنتين وفي منزل ترامب في فلوريدا الى
جانب وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان المشتركه
تم تقديم توصيه التاليه
سيدي الرئيس لدينا توصيه لك الهدف هو
الجنرال قاسم سليماني سيدي الرئيس سليماني
مسافر من بيروت الى دمشق ثم بغداد ويطيروا
عبر رحلات تجاريه ونعرف طريقته انه يتامر
لقتل المزيد من الامريكيين لدينا الادوات
الضروريه لوقف قيادته لهذه الجهود
الاجراميه لقد اسقطوا مسيرتين امريكيتين
اطلقوا صواريخ بالستيه على مملكه العربيه
السعوديه والان قتلوا امريكيا حان الوقت
لوقف حكمه الاجرامي هذا هدف عسكري مشروع
ترامب على الخطه المقترحه وبعد موافقته
جرى تحديد الثالث من يناير 2020 موعدا
للعمليه وصل سليمان الى مطار بغداد الدولي
حيث استقبله القيادي في ميليشيا الحشد
الشعبي ابو مهدي المهندس مع انطلاق موكب
سليمان والمهندس كانت مسيره
كيه من طراز ام كيو 9 ريبر تتقفى كل
حركاته معه مع مغادره سياره سليمانيه
المطار سقطت عليهما صواريخها الفاير
بومبيو كتب ان العمليه في مجملها استغرقت
خمس دقائق فقط دون قلق من وقوع اصابات
جانبيه بين المدنيين لان كل الخطط تمت
بعنايه
اسامه بلال البوجديني العربيه
[موسيقى]
في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه قال وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه في مقابله مع قناه سي بي سي
الكنديه ان الوضع العسكري في الشرق صعب
لكنه تحت السيطره واوضح ان الامر سيستغرق
بعض الوقت لاستلام الدبابات التي وعد بها
الغرب ومعرفه كيفيه استخدامها معربا عن
امله في اكتمال المهمه بحلول مارس
من جهات هي اعلنت الدفاع والبريطانيه وصول
الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين سيقومون بتشغيل
الدبابات الى العاصمه لندن وذلك لبدء
التدريب على قتالهم ضد روسيا واوضحت
الوزاره انها ستوفر دبابات تشالنجر 2
لاوكرانيا جنبلا الى جنب مع دول الشركه
مشيره الى ان التدريب سيشمل دوره اساسيات
سلامه الحياه ليتم التدريب على بنادق
هجوميه من سلسله ايكي وقنابل يدويه
وتدريبات عسكريا
اذا اعلام عراقيه يتحدث عن سماع دوين في
جارات وتحليق طائرات قرب مدينه القائم في
محافظه الانبار العراقيه
لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت التصعيد في الحرب
الاوكرانيه فكيف المنتشيا بقرار تسليمها
دبابات متطوره توصل التحضير لمواجهه موسكو
الباحثه عن تعزيز قواتها تحسبا لحرب
الربيع المقبله تغيرات كثيره طرات على ارض
المعركه تتزامن مع اعلان موسكو الاستنجاب
بالجنرال فاليري جراسيموف رئيس اركان جيوش
والذي كان في الاساس مهندسه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه اعاده كلاسي موف الى
قياده العمليه لم تكن اعتباطيه في هذا
التوقيت بالذات وذلك قبل اشهر قليله من
احتمال دخول المعارك من عرجا اخر مع نهايه
فصل الشتاء وذلك نقلا عن صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز معركه ستلعب فيها الدبابات دورا
نحاسما خاصه بعد القرارات الغربيه الاخيره
بتسليم حزمه من دبابات
الامريكي الالمانيه وهنا يمكن فهم سبب
استنجاد بيكراسيموف ربما الذي يسمى في
الاوساط العسكريه الروسيه برجل الدبابات
فهي اختصاصه الاول فما هي الخطه التي ينوي
القائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه اتباعها
في معركه الربيع دائما بحسب صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه فان غراسيم اوف سيعمد الى
دفع بالروبوت القتاليه ماركر حيث سيقوم
بتسليم اربع روبوتات الى بامبرز خلال ايام
وهي روبوتات قتاليه دواره قادره على
الدوران حول نفسها
540 درجه في الثانيه واحده كما انها
مصحوبه بالنظام لتحديد الاهداف
الى جانب ذلك تقوم خطه جرسيموف الجديده
على الدفع بالقذائف المحموله في جميع
الجبهات وابرز هذه القذائف ار بي جي سبعه
والتي ستعمل على صد جميع انواع المدرعات
الخفيفه والثقيله على حد سواء كما انه من
المرجح ان يقوم القائد الجديد بتسريع
عمليات حشد القوات الروسيه والتي شكلت
نقطه ضعف روسيه منذ بدايه الحرب
استخدام النوويه
[موسيقى]
الروسيه سيكون في مواجهه الجيش الاوكراني
في حلته الجديده والتي تختلف تماما عن
الشكل الذي كان عليه قبل نحو اي عند سن
العمليه العسكريه الفارق الكبير بين الامس
واليوم هو الاسلحه الغربيه التي باتت
تتدفق من كل حدب وصوب لتتحول الى الصداع
في راس بوتن والجيش الروسيه لكنه اوكرانيا
تتوفر على امتياز اخر الى جانب التدفق
الاسلحه وهو القدره على صيانتها صحيفه وسط
جورنال سلطت الضوء على ورص صيانه الاسلحه
المنتشره في بولندا والتي تعمل على اصلاح
الاسلحه الاوكرانيه التي تتعرض للتخريب
خلال المعارك ويعمل فيها مئات الفنيه
ولان خضوع الاسلحه الى عمليات صيانه يعد
امرا اساسيه في الحروب فان فريقا كاملا من
التقنيين يحرص على هذه العمليه من بولندا
كما ان بعض هؤلاء التقنيين على تواصل ده
اما على الجنود الاوكرانيين من اجل
اعطائهم توجيهات تقنيه بخصوص طريقه
استخدام بعض الاسلحه او كيفيه صيانتها ان
كان الامر ممكنا
ويضافوا هذا الدور الى ادوار اخرى لعبتها
بولندا في الحرب وبخاصه نتحدث هنا عن
دورها في امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه حيث
كانت المنفذ الاساسيه للاسلحه الغربيه كما
نعلم كما ان المعسكر الغربي وراهن على
بولندا للمساهمه في اصلاح وصيانه دبابات
ليوبارد بسبب بمعرفه بولندا الكبيره
التقنيين بولنديين طبعا بهذه الدبابه
الالمانيه اما روسيا فيبدو انها تفتقد الى
حد ما الى ورث صيانه الاسلحه وهو ما دفعها
الى الاستعجال في اطلاق عمليه انشاء
مركزين جديدين لاصلاح الاسلحه في منطقه
الموقف فضلا عن اجراءات عديده لسد الثغرات
كاتيا طعميه تطلع هنا على المسجد
كان للعمليه العسكريه الخاصه التي بداتها
روسيا في اوكرانيا منذ نحو عام تاثير كبير
على مجمع الصناعات العسكريه باكمله لروسيا
حيث قال الرئيس الروسي ضد ماركوت ان عمل
المجمع هو احد عوامل نصر روسيا في
العمليات العسكريه لذلك استجابه لاحتياجات
الجيش اتخذت السلطات المختصه اجراءات
عديده منها زياده وتيره ونطاق الانتاج حيث
تحولت بعض الشركات الى العمل على مدار
الساعه وزادت بشكل كبير من انتاج المركبات
المدرعه والذخائر وانظمه الصواريخ
المتعدده الاطلاق
وزادت حجم الانفاق على الصناعات الدفاعيه
في مشروع الميزانيه لعام 2023
[موسيقى]
اكد نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
العراقي فؤاد حسين في مقابله مع العربيه
اكد ان العراق بحاجه الى علاقات صحيه
وطبيعيه مع دول الخليجيه والولايات
المتحده وايران مشيرا الى ان العراق يجب
ان يقرر سياسته علاقاته الخارجيه على ضوء
المصلحه العراقيه وحدها
نحن بحاجه الى العمل مع الدول الغربيه
الاقليميه المحيطه بالعراق نحن بحاجه الى
العمل مع الدول الخليجيه الاعتماد
المتبادل سواء في الاقتصاد او السياسه او
الامن موجوده في في موجوده في في العلاقات
الدوليه اذا نحن بحاجه الى علاقه صحيه مع
هذه الدول العلاقات الطبيعيه مع هذه الدول
والعراق يجب ان تقرر سياسه العلاقات
وسياسه العلاقات تقرر على ضوء المسرح
العراقيه هناك مصالح حقيقيه واخرى لكن
بالنتيجه المصلحه العراقيه تقرر سياسه
العلاقات
العراقيه المتحده
اذا وسائل اعلام عراقيه تتحدث عن ان اصوات
الانفجارات بالقرب من مدينه القائم في
محافظه الانبار العراقيه الخبر الذي
اضعناه قبل قليل ناجمه عن قصف على شريط
الحدودي مع البوكمال السوريه وزير
الخارجيه العراقيه فؤاد حسين اكد ايضا
خلال المقابله الخاصه التي اجراها زميل
ماجد حميد انه يوجد بالفعل تهريب بالدولار
الامريكي من السوق العراقيه وهي مشكله
ليست جديده
وضع واضح انه كان هناك تهريب لدوران
للدولار الامريكي من السوق العراقيه وهذا
همم الى العلاقه بتنظيم العرض
وتنظيم الطلب اذا
مساله العرض يخص اجانب العراقي والمؤسسات
الماليه العراقيه من ضمنها البنك المركزي
وجانب الامريكي لكن مساله الطلب هذا غير
شيء اخر
وقف العربيه 360 ايضا
الابيض والاسود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
الايطاليه انطونيو تايانا نظيرته في حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه نجلاء المنقوش ستزور روما
مطلع فبراير المقبل لتعزيز التعاون بين
البلدين واضافت يعني ان ايطاليا تعمل على
توثيق التعاون مع ليبيا في عده قطاعات
وملفات من بينها الهجره والنفط والغاز
وجدد الوزير الايطالي استعداد روما لتوفير
الدعم وتحقيق التنميه في ليبيا لافتا الى
ان التعاون في قطاع الطاقه والنفط في غايه
الاهميه
ليبيا تتحول الى رقعه شطرنج بين ايادي قوى
اجنبيه بحسب معسكر الشرق الليبي والهدف هو
الفوز باتفاقيات استغلال مواردها الطبيعيه
وابرز اللاعبين على هذه الرقعه ابرز
لاعبين في الواقع ايطاليا وتركيا فبعد
تركيا جاء الدور الايطالي التي او جاء دور
ايطاليا التي وقعت اتفاقيه مع المؤسسه
الوطنيه للنفط الليبيه لانتاج واستغلال
الغاز وذلك في صفقه بلغت قيمتها 8 مليارات
دولار اتفاقيه تم توقيعها بين رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني ورئيس
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبي
اتفاقيه تطرح علامات استفهام حول طريقه
التعامل بين ايطاليا وتركيا التي سبق لها
وان وقعت اتفاقيتين في مجال النفط والغاز
مع طرابلس لكن على ما يبدو فانا انقره
وروما متفقتان بخصوص تقاسم النفوذ في مجال
الطاقه في ليبيا وذلك نقلا عن وزير
الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو
الاتفاقيه الايطاليه الليبيه تقتضي
بالاساس تطوير حقلي غاز قباله السواحل
الليبيه على امتداد ثلاث سنوات وهو ما
يختلف نسبيا عن الاتفاقيه الموقعه بين
طرابلس وانقره والتي كانت تسمح لتركيا
بالتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في المياه
الاقليميه الليبيه ورغم الاتفاقيات
العديده الموقعه بين تركيا وحكومه
الدبايبه في الاونه الاخيره الا ان
ايطاليا تبقى الشريك التجاري الاهم لليبيا
ولاسيه ما في مجال المحروقات حيث تعد
مجموعه الايطاليه اكبر شريك اجنبيه في
استخراج الغاز الطبيعي في ليبيا كما ان
الامدادات الليبيه تؤمن اكثر من ثلث
احتياجات استهلاك ايطاليا
يدفعيه عاديه جدا واذا تم اعتمادها من قبل
رئاسه الوزراء فهذه تعتبر اتفاقيه تعتبر
عقد رسمي وذلك وفق قانون رقم 24 لسنه 1970
اما ما يخص باتفاق السياسي في طبعا
ايطاليا الى مصالح في ليبيا من ناحيه
الهجره الاستثمارات حوالي ايطاليا
والمانيا تعيش حوالي 30% على الطاقه
يعني قرار او شخص يمثل الدوله الليبيه
بمعنى ان اا حكومات متعدده في في ليبيا
انا اعتقد ان الاتفاقيه هذه يعني مش مصالح
المواطن الليبي خليني اتفاقيات همم مصالح
الشركات همم الاعتبارات فقط
سراج همم حدثت همم في الترسيم الحدود
البحريه مع تركيا اعتقد ان الاتفاقيه
الموقعه بين همم ايطاليا وليبيا مع حكومه
بيقع الاشكال في حكومه دبي ذاتها
باعتبارها غير الشرعيه لا باس من توقيع
اتفاقيات في هذا التوقيت جديده خصوصا
ليبيا على همم طيره عقد كامل تشهد سرعات
سياسيه وضع امني اا متردي فالاقتصاد
بطبيعه اتحاد تاثر رفقه هذه همم المسارات
السياسيه والامنيه
اذا المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان يتحدث
الان عن استهداف سيارات تابعه لميليشيات
على الحدود العراقيه السوريه همم
ثلاثه انفجارات
ودوت في البوكمال تحديدا تزامنا مع تحليق
طائره للتحالف الدولي والاعلام العراقي
تحدث عن استهداف السيارات التابعه على
الحدود السوريه
لم يمر دون اثاره خلاف بين القوه السياسيه
فالرئيس الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان فتحي
بشغا رفض توقيع اي اتفاقات لها علاقه
بالغاز من جانب حكومه وذلك في بيان رسمي
ووصف اتفاقيه المجمع توقيعها بالغامضه
وبانها تزيد من حصه الشريك الاجنبي على
حساب حصه الشركه الوطنيه كما اكد عزمه
اللجوء الى القضاء لابطال هذه الاتفاقيه
واليوم اعلن السلامه لغويل وزير الدوله
لشؤون قضيا سحابه من حكومه دبيبه بسبب
حاله الانقسام وعدم تعبير الحكومه عن كل
الليبيين من جهته اعتبر وزير النفط والغاز
بحكومه دبيبه محمد عون الاتفاقيه تفريطا
في ثروه الدوله الليبيه علما انه غاب عن
مراسم التوقيع
وزاره النفط في حكومه دبيبه لم تستسغ
بالمره توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه من طرف
المؤسسه الوطنيه للنفط لتخرج بيانا مفصلا
بخصوص الموضوع الوزاره تعتبرت ان هذه
الاتفاقيه تمت بطريقه مخالفه تماما
للتشريعات القانونيه كما اعتبرت ان انفراد
مؤسسه النفط بقرار ابرام الاتفاقيات يفتح
المجال للشركاء الاخرين لاتخلي الاجراءات
مشابهه دون اتباع الاجراءات والتشريعات
المنصوص عليها في القانون الليبي المزيد
مع منير الاشهر
جدول القانوني حول احقيه المؤسسه الوطنيه
للنفط وحكومه لوحده الوطنيه في توقيع
اتفاقيه النفطيه مع شركه الايطاليه وبعد
تصريحات رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان فتحي باش اغا حول عدم شرعيه
حكومه الدبيبه واعتراده على زياره وتوقيه
الاتفاقيه هو وزير النفط والغاز بحكومه
بيبه محمد عون يفتح النار على رئيس
حكوميته ورئيس المؤسسه الوطنيه
غير قانونيه وان المؤسسه الوطنيه
بتحديد نسبه الشريك الاجنبي والمساءله
امام الجهات الرقابيه والتشريعيه
[موسيقى]
وفي تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 اكاذيب
مخزيه هذا التصريح من الخارجيه الفرنسيه
تتبادل روسيا والغرب الاتهامات حول كل
ملفات الكوكب بالتاكيد بسبب حرب اوكرانيا
لكن بينما يتبادلان الاتهامات لا تزال
ليبيا بعد اكثر من عقد على ثورتها هناك
تبحث عن حلول ولا يزال المسار السياسيه
فيديو اليوم منفيسه الامريكيه قصه تتكرر
باستمرار لامريكي يقتل بايدي الشرطه لانه
اسود لان العنصريه البغضه تسيطر على
الشرطه البيضاء في كثير من الاحيان كما
شاهدنا من قبل لكن واقعه منفس ليست كغيرها
ولن تطبق عليها الاحكام نفسها فسيكون على
الامريكيين الان النظر بعمق في اصلاح
الشرطه لان قتلت الامريكي الاسود طائر
نيكولز الخمسه لانهم جميعا يحملون لون
بشرته السوداء
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من القدس
المحتله لوالدي منفذ عمليات القدس الابل
مكلوم ينظر بحسره الى منزله الذي سيتحول
ان عاجلا او اجلا سيتحول الى كومه من
الحطام يده مغلوله يعلم انه لم يستطيع منع
جحافي للجرافات حين يحين الوقت المنزل
اغلق الان ولكن ينتظر هدمه في يده جرح وفي
قلبه الفرح على البيت الذي سيذهب ولكن قبل
ذلك على ابنه الذي
نختم العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار سعاده قطع
تتابع الان مع ميسون واخبار الساعه ميسون
مساء الخير ماذا لديك مساء الخير طاهر
طبعا سنطرق الى كل الملفات التي تحدثت
عنها وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للعربيه مع
زميله ناديه بلبيسي بالاضافه الى التوتر
الحاصل في الاراضي الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
وطبعا يبقى ايضا ملف اوكرانيا وروسيا
يتصدر الصحف شكرا لك